whatever you're thinking about it you
will not get it until you take action
make that move I exist to show people
what's possible I really do you need to
change everybody everybody out their
needs can change life is you can't
predict what you're supposed to do and I
tell people never kill yourself never
because you don't know what your future
is
hello believe nation I'm Evan Carmichael
my one word is believe and I believe
that entrepreneurs are going to solve
all of the major problems of the world
so to help you on your journey today
we're going to learn from actor Terry
Crews and my take on his top ten rules
of success rule number one is my
personal favorite and I'd love to know
which one you guys like the best and as
always guys if you're watching if you
hear something that really resonates
with you please leave it down in the
comments below put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired and when
you write it down it's much more likely
to stick for yourself as well enjoy
when you're young and your kid you have
so many I grew up in the hood man Flint
Michigan where I'm from and they say the
tech rules you can do anything you want
to do you can do anything you want to do
and then as soon as you go to class you
tell them what you want to do and then I
met what makes you think you're gonna do
some types that man is crazy yeah and I
say okay wait which one is it now can I
do it can I do it what right right so I
started to call people on that I started
to call people and I said you know what
I'm gonna go for it I'm gonna just try
something that I've never done before I
want to design furniture I want to be a
part of this thing so I'm going and you
know what happened it's not work people
started doing it started happening we
sittin furniture to Milan we should we
went in front of all the best people in
the whole world and it got accepted and
people were saying how great it was how
beautiful it was and I said man go never
let anybody talk you out of something
like that it never man never I'm a
dreamer take action whatever you want to
do whatever you're thinking about it you
will not get it until you take action
make that move make it a small step if
you want a house go get a rug you know I
mean if you want a new car go get some
car freshener take action make this
thing happen for you and it will happen
action action action you know one thing
that uh you know I can really attribute
to every failure in my life um whether
it be personal financial in any kind of
way business whatever it's because of a
lack of my attempt to take action I did
not take action and it kept me changed
once I got the fact that action is the
key it changed my life in many many ways
this is what trainers mess people up
I've had trainers who totally just want
to prove that you could never
do what they do and they have you pain
just to say like dog you know ain't go
to blast you like they want you unless
you're in pain and you feel like you're
sick and you're throwing up yeah that's
a workout no you look at you yeah you
have you heard you can walk great yeah
and the whole point is what I tell
people is treat the gym like a spa the
first time you ever go just go in there
and walk around that's the way to get a
drink of water walk around and then
leave and and I mean literally do that
for like a week two weeks until you just
get to the habit of getting in that door
because what's going to happen is
eventually you got to start listening
because you're there yes and you're
going to do something and you stop don't
ever get to the point where you're like
I can't feel my it doesn't work I've
been want people want they say they want
my body and all this stuff but I've been
working out consistently since I was 14
years old and I'm 44 I'm 33 years of
parkour to our workout 30 years yeah so
it doesn't happen overnight you just
have to enjoy the process
totally learn to enjoy it because I'm
sure there was a point where you started
to enjoy using a hundred thirty a pound
yep and that's only way you're gonna
keep going I tell people all the time
and I really believe this as I exist to
show people what's possible I really do
that's how it's like go for it try it
because another thing I am no different
than anyone else out there I am NOT here
to say I have a superpower and it was
all this it was just try it go but let's
see what happened yeah and all of a
sudden you get rid of judgement now you
can be creative but any bit of judgment
kills creativity any time you start to
go well maybe I shouldn't uh it's funny
because you look at a lip-sync or you
look at any kind of dancing or anything
like that
as soon as people see me being inhibited
you're done you're like oh I'll just guy
what if there's a but all they want
just even kill all you got just put it
out there and that and then everybody's
with you and let me tell you Terry Crews
is going to give you a hundred and fifty
percent know
matter what and that's I learned that's
my whole career you know how many times
have you ever heard the phrase you are
perfect just as you are have you heard
about me do you know what you're perfect
just as you are you are so perfect just
as you are but you know what you are not
you are not perfect just as you are you
are perfect but you're not complete this
is the thing and this is what I mean by
it and I people going to go away you
mean I'm what are you trying to say I
got to change
I got to change somebody else yes yes
you need to change everybody
everybody out there needs to change we
are designed for chain nothing in this
world stays the same
you weren't even getting better or you
are getting worse let me describe
something to you when I say you are
perfect but you are not complete that
see this building I mean if I look at
the blueprints but it's building it's
the blueprints for this building before
it was built or perfect everything was
in its right place everything was great
but could I walk in it could I do
anything did I have a building know why
it wasn't complete when they framed up
this building and put wood and metal and
all this stuff but they didn't do the
floor didn't do the electrical was it
perfect yes it was perfect that it
wasn't complete you I like this building
you are perfect in every way but you
just not done you're not done and you
know what anybody is trying to tell you
don't try to change me yeah now no one
to try to change you but you have to
change yourself you pop you tow it to
everyone to change yourself into a
better person into a better human being
that's what you have to do you are
perfect but you just not complete so
when you look at yourself look at
yourself like that building and it's
framed up and everything is in its right
place but you're just not done I want to
tell you that for anybody who's trying
to tell you
so I'm perfect is the way I am it's not
trying to change and guess what you know
and it's not worth it you're a half done
building who wants to live in a building
with no roof nobody I'm just trying to
break it down to you that you hear these
catchphrases you're hear this stuff all
the time
but everybody just takes it and says oh
yeah I'm perfect just the way I am and
you don't change and your life doesn't
change and you don't think it's better
for you and you wonder what's happening
and everything is crumbling around you
hey I'm guilty Terry Crews is guilty
then I realize wait a minute wait a
minute I'm not perfect just the way I am
I have to be perfected I am perfect but
I am NOT complete thing about
self-discipline is that it is necessary
for everything you do in your life you
have to be self discipline if discipline
comes from somewhere else it's very very
hard to remain consistent because you
tend to resist as well because I see
trainers and they're in the gym with
people and you know the guy or girl that
they're working out paints their work
out hates it because the discipline is
coming from somewhere else you it's
something that you dread every time you
go in you don't really want to do it
it's like oh but oh no my trainers here
he's about to you know beat me up and
make me feel crazy
well the truth is every trainer should
work his way out of your life anybody
who's working you out your teachers your
trainers your people they have to train
you to get out of your life so you can
go ahead do your own workout do your own
thing practice self-discipline now one
thing I want to straight now big-time
discipline is not punishment it's not
discipline is training that's all it is
I was talking to my son one time and I
asked him and it was weird because I was
trying to see if he really knew what it
was all about and I said hey man you
know I have to discipline you what is
discipline he goes punishment
when I do something wrong and you punish
me I think no no discipline is training
if you change your mind your mindset and
really focus it on what discipline
really is you start to welcome
discipline you welcome self discipline
into your life if you talked to me and I
was going I was in the football and I
was a football player and then you would
have told me I'll be doing what I'm
doing I would have said no you're crazy
leave me alone get out of here this is
why life is you can't predict what
you're supposed to do and I tell people
never kill yourself never because you
don't know what your future is
you just don't and that's the thing it's
like for me I never would have thought I
would be doing this but I decided to try
things I just decided that I didn't have
to do what everyone else said I needed
to do is like you know when you're a
football player everyone tells you this
would be the best route to do after
you're done well I decided to go another
way and then people thought I would fail
I remember when I moved to LA and ever I
said what are you doing your old
football player that's not no but they
don't care and I was hard I was actually
doing security for a little while and
you know I we went broke for a while and
put an amazing thing though is as I kept
trying new things new doors kept opening
and I never thought I would be an actor
but Here I am I'm acting I've been
acting for 15 years you never know
what's going to happen you never know
what what the future holds for you and
it may be acting it may be business it
may be performing it may be be home
making but whatever it is you have to
explore it you have to go for it one
thing I did that I wrote down my goals I
wrote in my top ten things I want to do
in life and if it fit in there I would
do it even if it was for free even if it
was even it was for free so you could
sing in if it fits my goal
then it's going to work out somehow
exactly nothing I've done a lot of
things for free where I always came and
paid me later right whereas if you if
you use money as the only way to go
you're gonna miss the right thing you
gonna make the right thing you need to
do right right so that's that's my whole
mentality is just to go all out all the
time I got one speed I'm all-in I'm
sleep there's no such thing as overnight
success because it took a long long time
I've been active for about 11 years but
to look at from when I started to
looking out at the billboard on Times
Square and seeing expendable sitting
there that's tremendously fast because
you know I mean I've never been in a
hurry but because I enjoy doing this so
much I just enjoy being around guys like
Stallone you know Micky Ward maracle
towards learning how to be a better
actor how to be a better person how do
you know these guys have done major
major things you know in athletics in
life and in all kind of ways kind of
took a sports mentality to my acting in
that focus you know it's not about you
know the party it's about the
performance you know to me um so when I
my goal was if I was gonna be funny go
all out like go to a point where they
like wait a minute okay yeah dude I
can't even air that you gotta you gotta
get rid of those haters in your mind now
on your mind totally it and then and
then the judgments that you hear and you
accept you start putting that on other
people totally so like a when a hater
tells you oh man you can't do that
that's because he's hearing that in his
head yes your honor me or you can't lose
all that weight that's because here the
laws work and he doesn't want to he's
afraid of the work that it will take for
them to do it it's really all fear it's
all hey it's a wild wild mix and I just
went out when I'm talking about that
it's like in your own brain there are
times when I do something so idiotic in
front of a group of people just so I can
get used to getting away from in the
morning in or whatever I'll do some some
of this stuff how's the say some dumb
you know deflect agenda
and it's like who cares right cares tell
you know I mean if I wear something dumb
who cares I walk around in a wig on who
cares if not you can't judge me I have
no shame it's not going to happen right
and that is where I started to go like
now I can go and be a great there's
nothing holding you back with tonight
you back did he do what you do in high
school dude I went from football to
basketball to track to break dancers
that's what I did I was I mean it was
the middle of the breakdance phenomenon
and I practiced like did you have a crew
oh yeah I had a crews are good we would
call it the big man breakers real
original the big name brands real
original we were all pretty big so raise
the weight yeah what use is this it's
like oh this was 86 84 I mean it's at
the height like that you know electric
Boogaloo was out in honor Baby B Street
was the beat yeah yeah really and did
you just like do cardboard down and lay
down and we had cardboard in the
basement man and I was practice pin it
on my head for hours yeah I mean no
girlfriends nobody would even get near
us really because you know like they're
spinning could they stop spinning
yeah you know we wanted to some sprints
right now yes please stop spinning he
wanted us to move I had the go-to move
which was the robot now I have the best
robot
[Applause]
that is a great long as I get older the
moves get more subtle because you like
I'm hurting guys but you see they're
just a little little touches that's all
you got to do now I love that you're so
much energy and so positive how do you
stay so positive and you know what the
key to energy I get that [ __ ] I got
that to me a lot but the key to energy
is gratitude
it's truly truly gratitude so the more
thankful you are the more energy you get
have you ever I've been where I was
ungrateful and you literally feel the
energy being sapped from you you know
what I mean but once you find one thing
to be grateful for all of a sudden you
get to energy to do things I'm from
Flint Michigan I am a statistic that
didn't go by the statistics because a
lot of my friends are in jail none of my
friends have died a lot of my boys are
no longer here and I look here I am in
front of the whole world all the time
doing what I love which is amazing you
feel energy I feel happy I feel joy and
that's when you sue anybody in the world
to find
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because the cast
actually do so that someone you'd like
me to cover in the next top 10 check out
the link in the description so you can
go and cast your vote I also want to
give a quick chatter - Jane Castel Jane
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word and posting
that picture online I really appreciate
it and I hope you're enjoying the read
so thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
people have heard the term purpose a lot
they always say you know you know you've
heard the term Purpose Driven Life and
you know what's my purpose I know I have
to be purposeful and the truth is you
know you do but a lot of people get
confused about what that really really
means when people think about purpose
they think you know what's the purpose
of my life my purpose is to be a good
person it should be a good person and I
understand it and you're right you are
not wrong about your purpose and being a
good person but you are not focused
enough let me tell you something when I
was young the whole thing about being
purposeful or having a purpose it's one
of the things where if you don't know
exactly where what you do on your job
you know I had a job one time it was
really hilarious
I actually worked at a liquor store and
I was in college and I remember just not
really knowing why I was there who's
just about getting my money and you know
my purpose was to you know restock some
things we kind of do some stuff and I
remember actually applying for another
job in the middle of it and I told my
boss like yeah you know I you know I
went for another job but you know I'm
just gonna be here until that other job
called you know she fired me on the spot
and I was shocked I was in there like
man why can't this woman understand that
I need some more money but what I didn't
understand was not pumping but being
named the perfect wood being able to
help her not be there until I get
another job and keep my mind all on
other things
my job was to carry those big crates of
soda just that restocked the cabinet's
rethought whatever I needed to do and
really you know do the cash register do
whatever I needed to do but my purpose
was we messed up it was wet and that's
why I got fired
purpose it's really about finding out
what it is you do
what is your role a lot of people get
this mixed up because let me tell you
something you don't get paid for what
you know you get paid for what you do
that's what you get paid for it that's
all so people will tell me I know all
that I know this and I know that but
what you know doesn't get you your money
only what you do and by nothing to know
exactly what to do you have to know
you're perfect
if you don't know your person you are
probably confused and you'll be out and
if you don't do what you're supposed to
do the world is going to miss what
you're supposed to bring they're going
to make what you have you must find your
purpose you must find what it is you are
always always meant to do that is the
biggest fight ever and once you find it
it's the key to your success is the key
to you being who you're supposed to be I
am the best
/ actor ever like if you give me
something and you tell me to do it big I
do it really big but I love that because
it's kind of my personality I'm a very
big personality I like doing things loud
I like being explosive and I like
attention so it all works together
you're going to mess up you're going to
see something that you didn't mean to
see you're going to eat something you
didn't mean to eat you're going to
overdo it you're going to binge you're
going to mess up you're going to fail
you are remember what that feels like
remember because failure really is only
temporary
if you don't take it as a loss if you
take it as a learning opportunity it's
only temporary but it can only be
permanent if you say you lose and you
give up that's the only way thing could
be permanent forgive yourself and move
on move on practice forgetting any of
the other junk that you did a mistake
you did let me tell you that
day is short and let me tell you it's
not a thing that you even have to
remember just go on and keep continuing
on the right path when you mess up start
over start over right away and I'm
trying to tell you you do that enough
you eventually don't mess up you
eventually it's kind of like a child who
falls down every time he gets up to walk
well you know he will fall down that's
just the nature of the beast
but let me tell you that the time goes
on he learns not to fall and you will
too
you will too but if you just imagine if
you were a kid and you fell down once
and you just laid there and you lay
there forever
well guess what it doesn't work that is
the same way you work that's the same
way even adults do sometimes you fall
down you missed the mark and you just
stay down there but you can do it